to view the full list of downloadable
programs available
financial journalist martin mayer is a
regular columnist for the wall street
journal his new book the fed explores
the workings of the federal reserve
next mr mayor talks about the impact the
bank has on the global economy it's a
little over an hour
okay
good evening everyone i'm carla cohen
i'm one of the owners of politics and
prose and i want to welcome you here
tonight
um we're extremely happy to have martin
mayer here
uh probably the the the most
recognizable name in
the as a writer of
about economics um in the united states
the history of banking
he um his
this book
seemed to be waiting for him to write it
a book that questions um
the position of the fed in the
in the in that we've had two books this
year that were
um about alan greenspan and the
the effect that he's had on the economy
through his position
as the head of
of the federal banking system
martin mayer takes it
takes us much further along by showing
us
the um
the and asking us questions about
where we want the fed to go and where we
want our economy to go
in the next
few decades
so it's with great pleasure that i
introduce martin mayer
[Applause]
thank you
um
this is this is a tremendously lucky
book uh it was it was finished august
1st all the editing done
um
everything ready to go
last august first and it should have
been published in february or so
um
and it would have been published in
february people would have sort of
scratched their heads and wondered what
it was all about and what was he talking
about and
it didn't fit into the ethos um
despite the 1991 experience
when uh
alan greenspan testified several times
before the congress complaining that
there seemed to be a 50 mile an hour
headwind that was that was preventing
the economy from reacting to what the
fed was doing
despite the collapse and it really is a
collapse of all of the theoretical
models of what central banks do in the
economy
despite the shrinking importance of the
banks themselves which are what a
central bank relates to
despite the clearly faulty assumptions
that were underlying all of the
descriptions of the transmissions
mechanisms by which
central banks and monetary policy are
supposed to influence what goes on in
the real economy nevertheless it was all
but universally assumed that monetary
policy would control the course of the
economy
the great statement of it and it may you
know may have a historical value was
paul krugman's in the new york times
when he said that when the economy turns
down everybody knows what the
prescription is you lower interest rates
and call me in six months um
and that you know we're now it's six
months
uh it's not getting better it's probably
still getting a little worse um
where you had a where in previous
slowdowns where you had basically a
monetary cause um
then you could by monetary means
solve the problem and of course in
october of 98 which is where my book
begins you had a
collapse of belief in the in the uh
financial mechanisms world worldwide
there if you could reassert confidence
confidence would do it and the economy
would come back here there is a greater
problem as there was in 1991 in 1991
there had been a great real estate boom
people had made clowns of themselves
over real estate banks had made plans of
themselves lending to real estate
projects that were never going to pay
out and there was a real problem
until some of that worked through there
was a limit to what you could achieve by
monetary policy uh this year we are
looking at the treatise of the
of the telecom situation where you know
the last estimates that have been made
are that five percent of um
uh the fiber optic cable that has been
laid is actually being used and it's
going to be some time before we get into
double digits on that so we had these
immense investments that were made which
are going to be losers and they're going
to be losers to an extraordinary degree
many of them a normal bankruptcy the
lenders get 40 50 60 70 80
with the telecom situation if you get 15
you're lucky um
so that we have a a real problem and the
notion that you can solve it by having
the chairman of the fed kiss it and make
it well has not struck me as something
that was that that was particularly
logical but if i when i said that in
august uh of last year
then i i did a work in progress seminar
with my colleagues at the brookings
institution um in this in the spring of
2000 and some very distinguished people
came i was very flattered by it and the
point that i was making i was trying to
get their guidance into what it all
meant to them
because i was looking at it and i
thought it was important but i wasn't
sure what it what it meant that
we were moving
from a from a bank-mediated financial
world to a market-mediated financial
world and the information systems of
banks and markets are extremely
different
banks
if they're working well and and my old
friend john hyman who was controller the
currency says that the error in this
analysis is that it assumes the banks
knew what they were doing which was a
strong assumption but
if if things are and you know when when
when the asian crisis hit um
uh treasury secretary rubin gave a talk
in this town uh
saying that that they went to the banks
to find out more about what was
happening in korea and they found out
banks didn't know anything about what
was happening in in korea nevertheless
certainly in theory and often enough in
practice and there's still enough
old-time lending officers around
the information systems of banks are
narrow but they're deep you look at
companies you know what companies are
doing you've been you've been through a
great deal of judgment uh process with
your uh borrowers you know what their
business is you've studied their
business plan you've kept an eye on it
you've had somebody going through the
files and you know
going in and getting your shoes dirty
and looking at what's going on but what
you know is that business and with luck
something about that industry
markets are broad and shallow the
information system of markets is very
short-term
um
and and looks does not try to understand
what the business is to anything like
the same extent we're having these great
examples now of people who were
supposedly distinguished analysts of
various high-tech institutions which was
which was selling stock through the
company that the analysts worked for and
it turns out that what they understood
about the business was limited um
but
in general markets cover of a a wide
range of experience there are a wide
range of people looking at it some
people know something about what they're
buying some people don't but the whole
system is subject to to wave motions in
part because it is shallow but it is
also broad the question of of how these
two information systems are going to
interact in a world where we still have
banks as important institutions but the
decisions are made increasingly by
markets and what is the position of a
central bank
working in a in a in a world
where the institutions that it is
designed to influence the banks are less
and less important and
this outside world of markets which are
not controlled in any significant way
by the central bank has become the major
factor i had my work in progress seminar
with my brookings colleagues and at the
end of it there was general agreement
that i was putting too much weight on
this uh that there was doubtless there
was some truth to it but that's not what
was happening and so i went back and
thought about it some more and i thought
god damn it that is what's happening um
and what i'm i'm dealing with is
accumulated habits of mind and you have
seen them over the course of these six
six months um that doesn't mean that
it's it's it's easy to understand you
know um greenspan looked at this problem
himself in the fall of
99 i guess and he's he sees good news
you know he brings certain elements of
good news to
the world he's basically a follower of
leibniz thinks that that all is for the
best and the best of all possible world
rational expectations leads you there i
mean if if the market is higher than you
think it ought to be it means that
people know more than you do um
and and uh therefore the you you get
certain
self-reinforcing trends and while
greenspan is a very careful
uh observer
and analyst of the information that
comes in nevertheless his instinct is
whatever is happening is for the best um
the right people are in charge uh the
right things are happening um the
productivity is going up and he
specifically talked about this business
of the markets and the banks and it says
means the central bank has two strings
to its bow if the banks aren't working
right and go to the markets if the
markets aren't working right that's
nonsense but he had to believe that
there's a need for an equilibrium
position here and that was his in the
fall of 98. um it's not so these are two
very different games they're not going
to work neatly two together and indeed
they don't
anyway this book which got finished in
august and would have
might not have sunk like a stone but
would live but the waves would have
obscured a lot of it had to be post
postponed for the reasons that mexico
gave you which is that uh the free press
which publishes it is owned by simon
schuster and simon and schuster
unbeknownst by the way to the people at
the uh free press had a contract with
uh bob woodward to do a book about
greenspan which in fact didn't get
finished until october but got brought
out one month after he finished writing
it um
and they did not want to have something
else on their list that might be
competitive to it so we got put off all
the way to june i think it is fair to
say i was pissed but it turned out to be
an extremely lucky event because the
book has had a lot more attention and
sold
not to be mercenary a lot more copies
than it would have if it had come out uh
four five six months sooner
um now
the uh
it's it's now become
obvious that what works with a highly
leveraged banking system where a central
bank can control the money so
supply is not going to be anywhere near
as powerful in its impact on the economy
when technology has made all financial
institutions congruent when people can
monetize most of their assets by writing
checks against the equity in their homes
or against the margin in their
securities accounts um and when interest
rates beyond the very shortest are set
not by the banks but in the markets when
when
years ago there was a prime rate and
everything was hooked to the prime rate
and then supposedly there were
there were rules of thumb they told you
how different uh loans should should be
at different maturities uh from the
bank's prime rate and there was a bank i
remember it was a bank called st louis
and southwestern that would get itself
some publicity every few months by
announcing that it was changing its
prime rate at a time when people knew
other banks were going to do that too
and at that point the fed which can
indeed control short-term interest rates
completely um
uh was a very powerful secret society um
there's a a great story that isn't in
the book but that i used in i don't know
why it wasn't in the in the book i used
in my wall street journal piece um of of
a few weeks ago great true story from
the memoirs of sherman measles professor
of economics at the university of
california and was a governor of the fed
back in the late 60s and
early year 70s and it's the story of the
time that nixon swore in arthur burns to
succeed bill martin uh who had been
chairman of the fed for 19 years uh and
burns was coming in to be chairman and
nixon invited the governors of the fed
to the oval office to be present at
burns swearing-in and they came um and
nixon was in one of his jovial moods and
said that how he hoped that burns would
lower interest rates make it cheaper for
the government to borrow ease conditions
in the economy that the that bill martin
had been awfully tough on the economy
which indeed in the last years of the of
the johnson administration he did
because he was trying to prevent the
inflationary impact of the vietnam war
and that he hoped burns would would take
it easier on the government and maisel
and his memoir said that it was
extremely embarrassing
for the governors of the fed who were
present at this occasion because they
had indeed voted a week before to lower
interest rates and to ease monetary
conditions and nobody knew the president
of the united states didn't know
that the federal reserve board had voted
to lower interest rates a week before um
the big banks the big investment banks
hired what were called fed watchers to
study the markets to determine whether
the motions in the markets were
related to a change in policy in the fed
because nobody knew
six months later they would in some
vague way let you know that the federal
open market committee had said this or
that vague
change in the instructions to the desk
that actually did the buying and selling
in new york
um but you never really knew what they
had done and certainly you didn't know
while they were they were doing it the
the banks were the key financial
intermediaries and bill martin's time in
the 50s and 60s and the years after
world war ii when banks
port portfolios were full of government
bonds and you could change the price
market price of the government bonds by
moving interest rates quarter of a year
percentage point um
throughout that that period what was
done was that the fed took an action
that influenced what the banks did what
the banks did influenced what happened
in the real economy the market caught up
with the real economy somewhat later the
market moved last but all of this was
started in this secretive way at the fed
um
today
you know
they come out in center stage at 2 15 in
the afternoon and if they're going to do
it between meetings greenspan will
probably time it to have something to do
with options expiration date so he can
leverage the speculative efforts of of
uh
market players in in in his way um and
it's it's now a very theatrical
enterprise it was a secret of enterprise
and it is now a theatrical enterprise
now the notion that this does not change
the situ i i can accept almost anything
i we can all be wrong i've known to be
wrong a lot myself but the notion that
these two institutions the one of which
was completely secret so that the
president of the united states didn't
know that they changed interest rates
and the other one in which somebody
comes out at 2 15 in the afternoon
and makes an announcement these are very
different institutions and one of the
oddities is that not only the outside
world has failed to recognize this the
fed has failed to recognize it uh it is
it is it is still it is a a a
staff-driven bureaucratic institution
that tends to duplicate what it did
before and that pays some attention to
the chairman but not much to other
governors um
when janet yellen was a governor of the
fed she used to say it was a wonderful
job if you wanted to go around the
country and make speeches written by the
staff otherwise if that's not what you
wanted to do wasn't so so great one of
the interesting
aspects of this story is that the event
that sort of gave the fed its charter to
move independently uh in 1951 the famous
accord not so famous the um accord
between the fed and the uh and the
treasury is virtually dropped out of the
history books um
my
my kids have gone through
good high school history course in which
they used college textbooks and i've
read through the ties no mention of the
a court there are there are
two very good biographies of harry
truman that i've read neither of them
mentions the
the accord but this is the charter not
only for the independence of the fed but
really it is the charter for the
independence of all the central banks
around the world which have now been
given much greater independence and my
my favorite story in this book
uh would really it's obviously been in
print because i i you got it somewhere
but it was in print in uh the privately
printed memoirs of alan sproul um
is the is the story of uh the day that
that that that the fight really blew up
between the treasury and the fed you're
talking about the early days of the
korean war the government wants to
finance the korean war on the cheap the
way it financed world war ii on the
cheap it wants to set maximum interest
rate of two and a half percent for
20-year paper and paid three-quarters of
one percent for one-year paper the
federal reserve is looking at an
inflation rate of which is approaching
six percent and saying you know if you
let the government borrow at these rates
then we're going to have an enormous
inflationary pressure we have to do
something about it um
and john snyder was then secretary of
the treasury he made a public speech
saying that because of the government's
monetary needs there's going to have to
be a large issue of paper and it would
uh be marketed quote within the pattern
of the rates which was three quarters of
one percent to two and a half percent
and uh mariner echols was then vice
chairman of the fed having been chairman
and he let it be known he didn't think
much of this and alan sproul was
president federal reserve bank of new
york and he made a public speech letting
it know that the fed was thought that
the federal reserve bank of new york
thought this was very unwise and truman
summoned the board of governors to the
white house the only time so as i could
find out in my research that the board
of governors was ever ordered to come to
the white house to meet with the
president and they did and truman said
no he said when i was a soldier in the
last war in world war one i put all of
my money into liberty bonds and when i
came back after the war
i wanted and i was going to start my
haberdashery i had to sell the liberty
bonds to stock the haberdashery and i
got 90 cents on the dollar that i don't
want that to happen to today's gis and
you know you have here at issue
nobody can argue with that um the the
understanding of what these interest
rate changes can mean to ordinary people
is something that you can lose sight of
very easily if you're a governor of the
fed nevertheless they have a
responsibility to maintain the value of
the currency so at the end of this you
know they went back to their meeting and
they said that's a that's a one can see
why the president feels that way but we
have an obligation to see to it even if
it means the government has to pay more
when it wants to borrow money
to make to make sure that the value of
the currency serve survives and from
this battle came the accord signed in
march of uh 1951
i tried to to get somebody interested in
doing an op-ed piece for the 50th
anniversary of the accord but it's too
obscure which is very strange it is it
is one of the you know if you're going
to make a list of 10 leading events uh
uh in the economy of the 20th century
this would have to be one of them um
but it's been it's been gone it you know
these these things affect people in ways
i my own contact with this sort of thing
is in the exchange rate question i wrote
the centennial history of the
metropolitan opera i wear a different
hat as a music critic and it's it's a
it's a gorgeous book i have nothing to
do with it being a gorgeous book the
iconography was by jerry fitzgerald uh
and it was put out for um
was put out for bids to printing
companies around the world and the
winner was dinah ponton in japan
and they did a gorgeous job it is really
a very beautiful book and they they
could do it at a price which made it
possible to sell the book in 1983 for 35
and the end was then at 280.
uh
that was when the contract was signed
the books were printed they were shipped
by slow freight to philadelphia they
were unloaded in a warehouse and they
were sold they were all sold i'm pleased
to say in about two months and they went
back to dine upon and said we need some
more books but the end was then at 1 60
and in order and and and the dine-upon
would have to charge 60 percent more per
copy to the metropolitan opera guild and
to simon and schuster which had jointly
published it so we've never been able
and and dine-upon will not permit its
place to be used by any other publishing
house by any other reprinter so this
book has never never been possible to do
a reissue of this book because of the
movements of exchange rates a very
abstruse question but it does indeed
impact on people's lives um
the key date in in in some ways is
probably the 1987
crash
um
uh
because the fed then found itself the
lender of last resort not to the banks
because the banks were not the important
phenomena i mean the the market dropped
20.8 percent in one day
the futures market dropped 28 percent in
one day this had never happened before
it hasn't happened since let's hope it
never happens again uh but there was
obviously a
a a crisis and there was panic and the
fed poured money out into the banks the
only place where the fed could pour the
money uh was by was by buying a great
deal of treasury paper pumping cash in
the banks and the banks clutched it to
their bosom because they were at least
as panicked as everybody else and the
guy who really made it possible for a
recovery to happen on on a very rapid
time scale was jerry corrigan who was
then president new york fed big tough
mick went around to all of these soft
bankers and and and
really in a very threatening way said to
them the money was not being supplied to
them for their use it was being supplied
for the market the specialist the
bankers trust was the largest lender uh
to the specialist community in the new
york stock exchange it had a portfolio
insurance program that was selling stock
to the specialist who couldn't buy it
because they didn't have any money
because bankers trust wouldn't lend them
the money i mean
all of this nonsense was was was going
on which carrigan put us put a stop um
but
at that moment with the fdic out there
to protect depositors
uh with the federal reserve
both in the theory of central banking
going back to badget and in a law
forbidden to lend money to insolvent
banks
so that there was a limit to how deep it
could it could reach in advancing money
but the fdic
was taking care of the depositors in the
insolvent banks the theory went
backwards the fdic became the lender of
last resort to the banks as we could see
in the 80s they didn't do a very good
job of it um and then the federal home
loan bank board of of course also with
the snl's and the fed in effect became
the lender of last resort to the market
um
it's a problem and it's an opportunity
there is a concept in economics which is
stolen from the insurance industry which
my friends at brookings didn't believe
called a moral hazard it's robert robert
solo first brought it up and what moral
hazard means is that if you insure a
house for more than it's worth someone
will burn it down
um and and
this and so we we have a situation where
there are a lot of people in the market
who believe in what they call the
greenspan put
it doesn't matter how dumb
you are or how much money you're going
to lose you will be protected at the end
because the federal reserve will come
around and buy it um
the the the fed is is desperately
anxious not to have people believe this
but we have long-term capital and
long-term capital was a classic case of
um you know of the fed being being
willing to put itself in a very bad
position in order to protect people
because they didn't know
uh how
well i what i say in in the book is what
they what they had learned is that they
didn't know what the banks had been
doing with long-term capital that their
own supervisory procedures had been
negligent and therefore they were
terrified that if this crowd went under
and you had a lot of investigations by
courts and by your congress the fed
would look very bad i think that was in
fact the basic reason for doing it but
certainly everybody else who was in the
hedge fund business looked at this and
said doesn't matter what we do we get in
deep trouble they'll come bail us out
and this is a problem um what's happened
this
this year
in my
analysis of these things
um
now
we now have i have to come back full
circle the question of what is the
mediating device for monetary policy uh
when we had a gold standard and karl
marx was active in england and studying
what had happened in the 1850s um
he said that what made that the way the
bank of england maintained the gold
standard main main maintained its own
possession of gold is that when there
was a drain of gold the bank of england
raised interest rates uh enough to lower
the price of paper of consoles in the
british market so that the french would
come in and buy it and when the price
got low enough the gold would flow back
in when the when they said that seven
percent would draw gold from the moon it
wasn't the seven percent that was doing
it it was the reduction in the price of
the assets um
to to get away from marx the probably
the most profound student of central
banking today is charles goodhart in
england and he has come around in
several talks this feeling that yes what
the central bank does
it's been effective because it affects
the price of assets now if you look back
you know if you look at sydney homer's
uh books about interest rates one of the
things that that homer insisted that
people learn is that it wasn't the stock
market that mattered it was the bond
market it was the it was the fixed yield
stuff and the price of that and quite
clearly if the fed changes the price of
interest rates it changes the price of
the of the
fixed yield instruments and now we have
moved to a time when the fixed yield is
considerably less important by
comparison to
the equity pieces and the fed finds
itself willy-nilly take and it's
definitely nilly nobody will admit that
they take an interest in the stock
market but finds itself with a need to
mediate somehow not only the bond market
the fixed income market but also the
stock market if you look at what
greenspan has been doing this year it
seems to me that what makes sense is
that he has been trying to avoid a
situation where the market fully
reflects the decline in earnings and
especially the decline in earnings
expectations so that
the
we aren't talking about the nasdaq
bubble which i mean there are people who
think this was a great tragedy uh up to
a point it was but if you know if
children didn't feel heat when they
touched the stove we'd have a lot more
three-fingered children around and and
they have to have some sort of learning
process you get something like the
nasdaq market in early 2000 um
but the the market as a whole really has
not done all that badly
and now you look at a world where
because of the influence of the central
bank there are fewer bargains than there
might have been otherwise and what this
is going to mean on the way back
uh we will we we will all find out i
sympathize basically with with with
greenspan's position uh
i am old enough to have uh to have
studied with joseph schumpeter who did
not really talk much about creative
destruction what he did talk about was
investment opportunities and the extent
to which the long waves in economies
were controlled by investment
opportunities which grew mostly in the
20th century out of technological change
and i still believe
that what has happened in the
information heck technology world is a
is a shrimpitarian revolution that
there's a long long time ahead of us of
heavy investment and i am enough of a
keynesian to believe that it is the
investment piece that governs what's
what's going to happen i like to make a
joke a little joke that if the fed was
really really wanted to help us these
days it would it would stop its
unrelenting opposition to
um electronic payments uh because one of
the things that has slowed down
the move in information technology is
that guys can automate their accounts
payable they can automate their accounts
receivable but they can't put the
payment piece in place because the fed
is protecting the jobs of the people who
work for the fed and process the checks
and the fed has made it extremely
difficult for us to move along the path
of electronic payments it is it is not a
major part of what's going wrong but it
would be nice if we could move it
forward the fed's reaction to this we
had a review of my book by bob mcteer
who was present federal reserve bank of
dallas in the financial times who said
that this was the silliest thing in the
book because the reason we haven't had
electronic payments is that people don't
want it and the fed being conscious of
what people want and don't want
therefore was not providing
on that note i think anybody who has any
comments or questions that's what i'm
here for yes um i wonder if you can
answer this uh each time the fed lowers
the crime rate
my bank
loads the rates it pays me on my cd
immediately and it's really hurting it's
going on again and again and again
and one thing that bothers me is i don't
see the logic of that the bank is saving
money when the prime rate is lower isn't
that correct they're paying less when
they have to borrow money they're paying
you less so but why they
they're gaining money by the lowering of
the rate why can't they pass a portion
of that savings to me the deposit that
will at least don't change my rate
instead of
lowering my instead of passing on any of
their savings they lower my rate
it makes no sense at all
they don't their savings come from the
fact that they can borrow money more
cheaply when you buy a cd you are
lending money to the bank excuse me when
you ask a question can you please stand
up um so we can see who you are and
repeat the question in case okay uh the
question was why do the banks lower
lower the rates on your cds uh on your
money market fund when the fed low is
the rates and the answer is because
that's that that's what they can do
everybody is going to be doing it the
fed controls the short-term rates and
you know
banks do do do well when rates go down
the sort of basic statement is that bank
liabilities reprice before bank assets
reprice that is banks have loans that
are six months a year two years longer
than that and those are if they're at a
fixed price that stays but they can turn
on a dime on what they pay when they
borrow money
because they can do it as they say
why don't they do it when the fed
doesn't lower the prime rate i mean it
makes no sense at all
what doesn't make sense is that they
don't lower the rate on your credit card
um
you know that that when they can get
money cheaper they don't lower the price
they charge for money they lower the
prime rate but fewer guys get the prime
rate um um
the problem
you know the banks mostly don't want to
do what they call spread banking anymore
anyway they want their their most likely
to sell their loans um
but they have to borrow money in order
to lend money and when they borrow money
they will borrow as cheaply as they can
when the when the fed puts more money
into the system which is basically what
the open market committee does when it's
lowering rates then the price of that
money is going to get down it's going to
and and the bank that pays more is going
to be deluged with money and find they
don't have any profitable use for it so
they're going to lower rates too they
just will yes bob
feinberg i think this
goes
with what the gentleman was just asking
um
without asking a leading question
in the 87-89 period
uh when the banking system was being
bailed out
it doesn't follow on what you're saying
that
the the fed drove interest rates down
that affected the price of that
assets
people like this they were trying to
raise the price of assets
they saw that that they could no longer
get the rates they were used to people
like this gentleman in the bank so they
took their money
two points one is they took their money
out of the banks and put it into the
stock market touching off the irrational
exuberance and
the second point is it allowed banks to
build rebuild their capital without
having to make loans
um
that's a something to hopefully for you
to work with
well
the the time
that the the interesting time period for
us right now is
97 when we had the asian crisis
98 when the whole world almost came
apart
99 when everybody was worried about y2k
on all three of these the fed put extra
money into the system
um
there is certainly a case to be made
i
i'm i'm i i'm agnostic but there's a
case to be made that
the nasdaq bubble was blown up
by the fed's actions in 97 to try to
bail out the asian situation in 98
when everything had had had frozen on
them and then in 99 when there was a
perfectly rational fear that there was
going to be major trouble on december
31st 1999
um
and that you wanted to make sure that
there wouldn't be any liquidity problems
associated with that so the money supply
whatever that word means
was probably much greater in the first
three months of the year 2000 when
the nasdaq bubble reached that
extravagant size uh than it would have
been without those three crises
and i am not it it is not in me to blame
the fed on any of those three because
they had a real problem they handled it
with the only tool they got and it may
well be
that
the bubble that was then created has
made the downturn worse now though the
downturn still isn't all that bad and
i'm not sure it's going to get that but
it's going to take a lot longer than
people have been thinking to get better
but i'm not at all sure that it is going
to be that that bad because i sense an
underlying maintenance of
of
of demand now this is very delicate work
let's just take a moment of sympathy
with the fed um
you you get these milton friedman
theories of of a steady growth of three
percent
but from the point of view of the guys
who are on the desk there's a cash
demand related to christmas there's a
cash demand related people going on
vacation on the 4th of july
there are companies that have extra
money because they're about to pay out
on the social security taxes for their
employees the government's money in the
bank in the banking system which is
billions and billions of dollars every
day that fluctuates the treasury's tax
and loan accounts and the guys who are
working the desk have to balance all of
these things the thing that begins every
day at the fed is a call from the
treasury to tell the guy who's running
the money desk how large the treasury's
balances will be in the banking system
that day and one of the oddities to me
of the work on this book is that neither
the treasury nor the fed would supply
that fellow to me the guy who did it on
the fed side was peter fisher who was
easy to talk to but you could not
through the treasure treasury said there
wasn't such a person basically um
but and and but that enough it's a it's
a purely technical and mechanical job um
but it has to be done done done well
then over and above that
you lay the problems of monetary policy
so that we we aren't talking about
something this the big argument in
economics some years ago was between
quote rules close quote and quote
discretion close quote and what the
friedmanites was saying is that you must
have rules for the central bank to
follow and volcker at one point tried to
do that um
and that it doesn't work because
people are variable and what people do
tomorrow there's a um
uh there's a there's a wall street
economist who makes a presentation and
he he draws a graph
and um the x-axis is time and the y-axis
is the degree of human involvement and
the closer you are to the abscissa where
you have the least time and the least
human involvement the better your
mathematics is going to be the further
out you go in either directions the less
useful your mathematics is going to be
let me let me get other people yes
gentlemen over there
when if you make a further comment about
the change in the secrecy and the
operation of the of the fed something
about his genesis was it changing the
style of the chairman or
concern about leaks in the media or
changing society or what's your analysis
of that it's i
it's being forced upon them by
technology
it isn't something they like very much
as a matter of fact the fed has
requested the congress to increase the
penalties on people who reveal the
contents of bank examinations during
this this this period when they've been
more open
in some other ways but
we are if you're going to have a
market-dominated world markets are going
to work best with more information
um
and
greenspan is is very conscious of this
and he talks a good game on uh
disclosure he doesn't really feel it and
the institution doesn't feel it at all
but
if you're going to have a
market-dominated world you're going to
have to have much more information out
there my own instinct is that the
umbrella regulation aspect of financial
institutions and once the computer was
there and you could run through all the
accounts every day
if you were an insurance company if you
were a brokerage house if you were a
bank whoever you were once the computer
opened all the accounts every day
routinely the difference between a bank
and an insurance company and brokerage
house was very greatly diminished um and
when you got that
when you you got that degree of access
to information that once only banks had
um
then you really had to start opening it
up um
the problem that the fed had was that
when bill martin was chairman and the
banks did two-thirds to three-quarters
of all the financial intermediation
then um
you could you could keep things secret
but now the banks do 20 of the financial
intermediation and they do that
gracelessly you know you have a mortgage
the bank isn't funding the mortgage that
mortgage is out there being funded by
fannie or freddie or some insurance
company you have an automobile loan the
bank isn't funding that automobile loan
it's out as an asset-backed security all
the loans the banks can sell into the
market they want to sell into the market
so that the role of the central bank
which once what on this this question
that i was asked about you know they
lower the rates why
why does why do they lower the rates on
me all of these things which once the
banks were supposed to be
able to make the decisions they can't
anymore the market makes the
decisions therefore over time you're
going to have to move toward an sec
orientation with regulation and access
to a lot of information and away from
the banking
area where the i mean the basic concern
of a bank and of a central bank is is
confidence
herman herman melville wrote a great
novel called the confidence man which he
was never able to finish and one of the
reasons that i don't think he could in
his own mind decide whether this
confidence man was going on a
mississippi river boat was really god or
was really a con man um and that's
that's what you have now with the with
so they've got to get the information
how people can make up their own minds
um
i take too long yes gentlemen over there
at the end of the day do you think what
greenspan's been doing for the past six
months makes sense and is it going to
work in terms of the economy
and or the markets
it's it's worked
i think it's it's done as much as it was
likely to do
uh what's going to work is is
the growth of investment opportunities
again um you know if if the new
microsoft if if microsoft this is half a
joke but only half if the new microsoft
program can really be sold to the
american people as something they need
and if it's a lousy clunky program like
all the other microsoft programs you
can't run it on the computer you own
you're gonna have to buy a new computer
to run it that that that'll be a big
help um but there are there are there
are all sorts of of things coming around
which people are going to be
guys who run businesses are going to
feel they can save a lot of money on
they can exploit for various profitable
opportunities or they will be afraid
that other guys in their business will
be using it and will disadvantage them i
think that the the innovative
possibilities are
are still so great with all of this
equipment and with the new programs and
the and and the improvements and the
speed of the chips and such things um
that there will be a groundswell of
demand again in this area and that's
what got gets you out what gets you out
is not just that you reduce the interest
rates if in fact you got the stuff now
and it's not servicing its own capital
costs
yes gentlemen here i'll be there
coordination around the world i mean
something like two-thirds of
the dollar
are outside of the u.s and and
you know if all the economies are down
as they seem to be now
there's no really good place to put the
money and
how do you get out of that conundrum
uh
[Music]
well what what what has happened
for most of the post-war period is that
when the world gets worried it wants
dollars um
and um
that's been happening again this year
uh and it's interesting because we
weren't that conscious of the worries at
the beginning of the year but quite
clearly there's been an inflow you could
explain the inflow of capital this is a
country that has a 300 billion a year
trade deficit
um we have to have a lot of money coming
in so we can finance that trade deficit
uh
one of the numbers that i pay a lot of
attention to is
a number published by the federal
reserve bank of new york every thursday
which is the
quantity of treasury paper now treasury
paper plus federal agency paper
held by the federal reserve bank of new
york for a foreign official account for
foreign governments and foreign central
banks that's 700 billion dollars that's
a lot of money um
if foreigners want dollars
then
that number doesn't go up because they
take their dollars and they buy american
instruments of various source with it if
foreigners decide they don't want
dollars then that number does go up
because they take their dollars to their
own central bank they get mark's euros
now frank's pounds whatever with it and
by by an agreement worked out by arthur
burns in the early 70s the foreign
governments and central banks shipped
the money back here to be invested by
the federal reserve bank of new york
to date
our trade deficit is being financed by
an autonomous inflow of dollars
this has
its side effects in terms of the fact
that the dollar is high our exports are
expensive we can import more cheaply and
this we weekend this takes too long um
but
what will happen to it
in theory this was going to be the year
of resurgent europe we were going to
have a moderately tough year they were
going to have a great year it would help
us as they got as they pulled out of
their problems um
markets presumably uh equilibrate a lot
of this stuff um
but they don't work because in in in the
way they are supposed to fairly often
because there are these immense
psychological factors uh as part of it
i think most of us have been surprised
to see the euro continue to weaken
against the dollar um this is not what
anybody expected or wanted but the
notion that you can control it by
waiving a one i mean jim baker and the
plaza agreement and all of that stuff
from the 80s demonstrated reasonably
well that there's a limit to how much
you can do on that um
it's
it's not by the way essentially
the central banks get involved in this
but the exchange value of the currency
is a treasury department problem and the
fed is a handmaiden in that area always
has been and i suspect always will be
one of my favorite stories was from 1981
82 i went to see volker whom i've known
since we were both kids and i said you
can't keep it up that's when he hit the
interest rates at 20 percent and he said
why not
i said because it's because you're
bankrupting the third world and you're
destroying the cross rates in europe in
other words people in europe uh would
not sell
would not sell marks to buy dollars
they'd sell franks to buy dollars so
that the relationship of the mark and
the frank was being uh very grievously
affected by what we were doing with our
interest rates which doesn't make much
sense um
and he said
uh he said other people have their
problems he said we have our problems
i am hired to take care of our problems
central banks are very nationalist
institutions treasury departments can be
affected maybe by the foreign minister
but the central banks much less so this
doesn't answer your your question it
doesn't have an answer presumably at
some point in the game and one hope it
is when hopes it isn't drastic and
sudden and difficult to manage uh it
will once again come to the attention of
the people who are moving money around
the world that we have this huge trade
deficit and i should fancy that at that
point the dollar will begin to sink but
certainly hasn't happened yet
uh you bring poland into the uh eur as
it's not in into the east uh ecu as it's
now operating and we don't know um
anyway yes gentlemen here
bearing in mind that the
central banks can
affect the markets directly by
increasing the money available for
investment
on an international basis could you
speak to the coordination between at the
international level between central
banks
yeah
i i think
um
the bank for international settlements
is where a great deal of this
coordination among central banks occurs
um
johnny johnny heims with an honorary
central bank has said that they get on
with each other very well because nobody
else likes them um
the uh
it's
these are once again nationalist
institutions they're going to look at
what they assume to be the credit needs
of their own economies uh having said
that
we have a situation now obviously where
uh
the european countries have joined
together in a common currency which will
exist in physical form in january um
and where latin america has
has dollarized to a degree that we could
not have expected before um
what this is going to mean i mean
no no central bank well greenspan in 97
made this interesting comment the united
states could not expect to be an island
of prosperity in a sea of
depressed
economies the first time i had ever
heard a chairman of the of the fed talk
about the need to respond to foreign
concerns
um
and i think that there is more
coordination now
uh
though obviously there is not an
agreement between um
uh the european central bank and
the fed about what the world needs the
european central bank has not been
willing to cut rates the fed has been
cutting rates drastically um
the
bank of england has been somewhere in
between uh
so that what you've got is is people who
really see the world and and what they
can do differently um
the the question of investment
opportunities you know
if investment opportunities are being
constrained by tight money and interest
rates go up that's one thing if you're
going to try to create investment
opportunities by lowering the price of
money
um
you've got to change the hurdle rate at
which people are willing to to put money
in and that's difficult to do at a time
when the economy is going down that's
one of the reasons that my feeling is
that what the central bank does in a
slowdown is try to try to keep the price
of existing assets a little higher by
putting up more money um
but the the real economy is going to
have to take care of
uh
return of of what keynes called the
animal high spirits of businessmen you
can't do that with monetary policy
demonstrated that in the 30s yes i may
ask you i'd like to come back to this
rules versus discretion discussion i
mentioned earlier
what do you think is the
interpretation the
fed has of its of its uh mandatory price
stability obviously it doesn't have any
rules like a fixed money growth rule or
an inflation target as other countries
have
some academics however have
thought that well
the fed may have a hidden rule like a
taylor rule for example so these kind of
things
the fed may have a tailor rule mr taylor
would know presumably yeah right but
what do you think how does the the board
interpret this this mandate of price
stability is there a range of inflation
they have in mind or i don't well i i
think that that that greenspan and i
mean they've been been willing to
tolerate more a
more inflation
this last year than one would have
expected uh they have certainly taken a
very different attitude in the ecb i
mean both uh greenspan and larry meyer
and others are out there saying there is
no inflationary pressure these these
numbers that you see are artifacts of
other things uh because they've been
most concerned about the slowdown um
the
other
country's central banks have a specific
mandate to maintain the value of the
currency
in its wisdom the congress has given the
fed a lot of mandates it's supposed to
maintain employment it's supposed to
maintain the value of the currency it's
uh it's it's supposed to make sure that
poor people get access to credit it's
supposed to do a lot of things that the
world's other central banks don't have
to do um
if there's a there's a good book uh by j
uh by melton i've forgotten his first
name now called inside the fed from
about 15 years ago which looks at the
targets that the fed is at various times
looked at i mean the fed targets the big
things it targets growth
it targets inflation um and it targets
unemployment or employment but of course
you can't do that with monetary policy
you must choose a quote intermediate
target close close quote which
presumably has some direct sort of
wheel and spokes relationship with your
big targets at one time and another the
fed has the fed through most of its
existence has targeted interest rates
first place that's what it can really do
um
in the volca years for a while partly
because of the immense inflationary
problem of the late 70s and early 80s it
targeted
monetary aggregates
there's a little colicle between
greenspan and volca that was overheard a
few years ago walking into a meeting
when volcker said sort of casually
whatever happened to m1 and greenspan
said it was a pretty good rifle
um
but
you don't these things don't work at
this point in the game if i can write a
check against the equity value in my
home what is the money supply you get
infinitely expansible velocity because
it will turn up as as as uh velocity
rather than a monetary aggregate every
once in a while greenspan says sort of
wistfully that maybe m2 is beginning to
have an impact again
the amount of curve fitting that had to
be done to make m2 look as though it was
a causative thing uh was just too we're
great the answer to your question is
that
um greenspan is himself a hugely
pragmatic person i you can put it
negatively by saying that he steers the
boat by its weight he studies what has
been happening and he makes short-term
extrapolation
he's very very good at it whether that
and and for the period that he has been
chairman of the fed that has been a very
good attitude whether that is over time
going to be enough
uh given the collapse of the models i
don't know um
but the fed at present is trying to do
whatever it thinks works it does it does
it does not have rules and it does not
greenspan also made a talk the group of
30 in which he said quite dead pan and
these central bankers and big shot
bankers listening didn't even laugh at
all he said you know he said we at the
fed spend more money on economic
analysis and on mathematics and on the
creation of economic models than anybody
else in the world and as a result we
have the best models and the best
forecasting models in the in the world
and the fact that these models have been
wrong for 14 straight quarters does not
mean they will also be wrong in the 50s
you're stuck with that problem you get
pragmatic i think we have a couple of
minutes more
yes gentlemen back there
you
recounted a number of instances where
heads of state
we're trying to influence uh
central bank policy
now
uh
many countries in the world are now
creating central banks
which are independent for the first time
isn't uh imitation the best form of
flattery yeah
yes i mean the the the system that was
created in this country in the federal
reserve which rested upon
central bank control of the creation of
bank liabilities elsewhere in the world
the basic control was on the creation of
bank assets um in this country we said
we're going to we we're going to limit
the creation of bank liabilities and
we'll let the market determine what
these bank liabilities are used for um
and uh
for that purpose you can have an
independent central bank if you're
trying to to to give guidance
administrative guidance as the british
and the french in their different
languages and the japanese called it
then you you you tell the banks where to
lend and where to create the assets we
went in the other direction and created
an independent central bank that would
influence creation of bank liabilities
we have now got to the point
where it's much more difficult to
influence the creation of liabilities
because it's not being done by the banks
it's being done elsewhere um
nevertheless this effort to create a
central bank would be independent of
politicians uh the great example of
course being new zealand you must keep
in mind that in new zealand there are no
new zealand-owned banks um
the um
but certainly the the notion that the
french government would give up control
and you know in this country there was
jaw boning of the of the fed forever
until uh clinton and ruben shut it down
when volcker was invited by reagan i was
invited by by by jimmy carter to become
chairman of the fed he went down he
didn't want the job much um he was being
paid
two-thirds again as much as president of
federal reserve bank of new york and in
many ways it's more interesting job um
but uh he went down with a list of of of
things he wanted jimmy carter to promise
him of which the first one was there
will be no sniping from the white house
and no second guessing by the kids
around the white house and and carter
said yes but he didn't mean it but
clinton thanks to ruben in in large part
did mean it and bush has clearly decided
to stay with that you know
given what the economy has done in the
last six months it's very hard to
imagine an administration prior to
recent years that would not have been
jaw boning the fed to move faster and do
more and indeed my own feeling is that
greenspan moved in january when he did
because bush was meeting with the
with the grand dust with the grand duffy
charlie the big shots of u.s business
and they were going to call for lower
interest rates so he moved in midday
before they could come out in the
afternoon and do it
but but certainly
there has been remarkably little sniping
at greenspan there has been remarkably
little insistence that the fed could do
more
um
and it may be that we have entered into
a time also where this is considered a
professional re responsibility rather
than a political football i wouldn't
tell senator sarbanes that because i
think his instincts still go back to
trying to influence what the fed does
but certainly it's not being done now
velocity like productivity is is is one
of these things that you put in at the
end because you got to make the equation
come out uh it's a it's a it's a it's a
residual the
transactional velocity of money is just
incredibly great we are talking about
trillions of dollars every day that
moved through the new york clearing
house and moved through fedwire and
moved through the foreign exchange
systems and and and now moved through uh
uh the euro world where it's managed by
a private operation called sprint um but
the income velocity of money
is something that you get
later by looking at at what you say the
gross domestic product was which is not
a very good number and what you say the
money supply was which is not a very
good number and that tells you how often
that money supply had to turn over to
make the i the identity work of money
times of a lot quantity times velocity
equals transactions times price
okay but as far as
the consumer the people gathered here
today
which
vehicle would offer them the greatest
efficiency
in this velocity equation would it be
banks
or investment houses or insurance
companies well the
the brokerage houses have have pioneered
uh multi-purpose accounts which have
been very efficient and useful for
people banks now offer them too but
there's no question that that that uh
the cash management account which
merrill lynch pioneered in the late 70s
was a remarkable benefit for consumers
and you have to give merrell
credit because the largest single source
of its income was free customer balances
um the money that was just left in the
house when people sold something before
they bought something else or when
dividends were paid and before they were
sent out and they didn't pay interest on
that and because that would have been
taking deposits which they said was
illegal and then suddenly they moved to
give up that income in order to create
this
uh account which would tie the customer
to the brokerage house rather than to
his customers man and it worked very
very effectively my hunch is that that
sort of account is still better done
by the brokerage houses and maybe some
of the electronic guys like schwab than
it is done by the banks because banks
tend to be slow moving okay thank you
all very much
[Applause]
that would be great he'll be signing
right here
to my left
martin mayer is a regular contributor to
the wall street journal he's been
talking about his book the fed the
inside story of how the world's most
powerful institution drives the markets
it's published by the free press for
more information go online to
simonsays.com
[Music]